it was our soul and our blood washington
post columnist michael kelly was killed
last night while covering the war in
iraq he was embedded with the army's
third infantry division and was killed
in a humvee accident he's the first
american journalist to die in the
current conflict
in 1993 we spoke with michael kelly on
book notes we discussed his book about
the first gulf war titled martyr's day
chronicle of a small war
michael kelly what's the reason for the
title of your book martyr's day martyr's
day is a
day every year in which the iraqi
honor their war dead
which is a fairly large population in
iraq since they've been engaged in
one war another ever since the bath
party took
took office and on that day
by decree of the state
there is a ceremony held in iraq
at the marchers monument in which
war widows and and war orphans and
various other people go to have the
official ceremony honoring the dead and
i went to it
um
the on the mardis day after the end of
the gulf war and attended the ceremony
as a reporter and it struck me at the
time as a
wonderfully emblematic
moment uh
about iraqi society about the
the wretchedness that iraq was about the
uh the wretchedness of the lives of the
people there this is
what is supposed to be a great day of
national emotion
and the but it is really something
utterly machined by the the state by the
bath party so that the people trooping
up to
pay their respects to the dead with
their banners and their bouquets of
flowers
are one after another
party hacks or bureaucrats or military
they are functionaries of the state
every single one of them and i had a
minder with me a gentleman from the
ministry of information and culture who
was assigned to watch over me
and at one point he uh
he saw he was he was whispering in my
ear what each deputation is you know
this is the iraqi students association
this is the iraqi doctors association
all of which are party organizations and
at one point
he saw a deputation come up and he got
excited he said why they have no banner
perhaps this is just ordinary citizens
and then the wind shifted in it blew
over banner and he said oh no it is the
ministry of the interior after all and i
thought you know this
to me that was a moment and i i wrote
the first chapter of the book
about that a small chapter just to sort
of set the tone i took the title from
that
before we get into some of the contents
of this
give us the time period that you were
over in the middle east i went to uh
i went to iraq uh the first time to
baghdad about a week before the war
began and stayed through the first night
and day of bombing uh that
that was the opening of the war
in baghdad and then left
to go to oman and then
from oman on to
tel aviv and
saudi arabia
to kuwait and iraq for the ground war
to kurdistan for the uh kurdish
rebellion and it's in the flight of the
kurds and then back to
finally back to baghdad last time about
a year after the war ended
uh for my last trip so it
most of my traveling was over a period
of about a year from just before the war
began to about a year after it ended who
were you working for when you were over
there in those days i was uh working for
myself which is a nice estate for a
writer to be in and
i suppose the reason i was able to
see all that i
i was able to see because i didn't have
any bosses telling me to
come home or to leave a place
and i was uh stringing for the boston
globe uh and writing magazine articles
for the new republic and for gentleman's
quarterly
did you come close to
either
death or being injured in any way i uh
came
close i supposed to uh
to something along those lines a couple
of times i i
found the first night and day in baghdad
with the bombing uh
frightening but i don't suppose that i
really was in any
danger i mean
i was underground in a bomb shelter
much of the time and when i was outside
during the
the day i
nothing fell near me um
and the bombing was remarkably accurate
um most of it was uh
most of the rest of the time even going
through the ground war uh traveling with
a reporter friend of mine dan festerman
at the baltimore sun was was not too
dangerous the only thing i suppose it
was dangerous was uh
going back into kurdistan at the end i
got uh
i was traveling alone in the
kurdish held part in the north of the
country
which was illegal of course and
i got dysentery then and uh it proved to
be such a fast illness and so
debilitating that i uh
got very sick and couldn't move much i
couldn't keep on walking and hitchhiking
to get out and
for a few days there i was scared how
did you get over dysentery i found uh
somebody some rebel uh kurdish uh
peshmerga troops took me to the
a mountaintop headquarters of jalal
talabani who was one of the kurdish is
still one of the
two primary kurdish leaders and
being a big shot he had a doctor
and his doctor had
a little bit of antibiotics not enough
to get rid of the sickness but enough to
sort of [ __ ] it
and uh
eventually uh nine or ten days later i
was able to get out of uh
sort of kept walking and hitchhiking
rides
to the turkish border and uh was able to
cross the river there and into turkey
where i could get
and get to see a
a real nut he was a real doctor i guess
in iraq but the doctor who had supplies
who's max max is uh my wife
madeleine
and she was
in the war at the same time i was
which uh
made it a kind of a nervous making
experience for both of us because i was
in the arab world and she was in the
israeli
world which as you know there's almost
it's very hard to communicate between
the two
she was in tel aviv as a producer for
cbs news during all of this gut attacks
when at times when i was in baghdad or
amman
we would keep in touch via new york
telephone calls from amman to new york
to tell her even someone which is
a sort of routine dodge that everyone
does over there you two got together
during the war we did for her birthday
in tel aviv uh
and a night on which happily enough
there was a no scout attack and
instead we went to a very good party
you're doing what now now i'm a white
house correspondent for the new york
times
did
did this experience over there lead to
this job now
i suppose it did when i i had written a
number of uh
a bunch of stories for the new republic
and those were pretty well uh
received and when i got back uh to the
states uh at the end of the war and
was busy writing the book hal rains who
was then the washington bureau chief
asked me to come in for a talk and he
and i talked and that led to a job
when you set out to either go to the
middle east and cover the war or write
this book or a combination of both what
was your mission
i wanted i i didn't know at the
beginning that i had any mission i'm not
uh
i'm not a very organized person and i
started it out almost by accident i i
wanted to
to go to baghdad and see the beginning
of the war and write something about it
i had no
larger thought in mind
but once i started it
i got more and more
i suppose uh impressed by what seemed to
me
a great difference between the texture
of what you could see
on the ground
the way that uh war this war or any war
um the remarkable things that happened
in a war though the things that happened
to people in the uh astonishing displays
of emotion cowardice and bravery and
uh
terror that you see all around you all
the time so
i got impressed between the difference
between what i was seeing there and what
it seemed to me
the war was being
uh presented as
not by any conscious design but i
suppose just by an accident of
circumstances in an almost euphemistic
way is a rather bland
uh antiseptic
uh event
that the public face of it was often
a reporter standing in
outside a briefing room or reporters
asking questions in a
in a briefing room or something and i
thought that much more was happening
that there
should be
that while television
had fulfilled this extraordinary role in
the war of making it
the first war in video time the first
war that video cameras could actually
capture and put out on satellites that
there should be a place for a writer to
to pay attention to the very small
details
and
work at carefully describing the the
things that actually happen to
individual unimportant people in a time
of war
because i think that's an astonishing
time you see things that you don't see
at other times i saw
one of the things that struck me
during it
i was watching uh one day in kuwait city
this uh
young man standing in front of a
television crew in an abandoned theater
in a concert hall really in kuwait city
and the television crew had bought him
to that spot because it was the spot
where he had been tortured by the iraqis
and they wanted
him to stand in front of the of the
place where the torture rack had been
and recount the tale of his own torture
which astonishingly enough he he was
willing to do
and while he was doing it and the video
camera was capturing this he was
silently crying and the tears were
streaming down his face as he talked of
his own torture and
and the
producer
whispered instructions
to the cameraman to get the right sort
of shot and everything i thought that's
an astonishing scene to see something
like that and the only way you can
can capture that is by writing about it
later at a remove and trying to get it
down just so
you see in in normal life almost nothing
like that you you might see in the
course of a lifetime two or three people
cry
in a war you i probably saw 30 or 40
people cry
people cry all the time it's a routine
event you walk down the street and you
see somebody crying you don't even know
why
and i thought a writer might be able to
put some of that down on paper where'd
you learn how to write
from my father
my father is a newspaper man
and i and a lovely writer and i started
studying his style when i was
very young six or seven i suppose what's
his name tom kelly where does he write
he writes now for the washington times
and he's
working about two-thirds of the way
finished his first novel a mystery novel
set here in washington in the great
depression
born in washington born in uh washington
grew up in fourth in constitution
i wrote down the front of the book that
or the accident the back book where
you're
in your bio the places that
of course now that i'm starting this i
haven't got the page open where you've
lived it'd probably be easier for me
just to ask you here it is
i've got washington new hampshire new
york cincinnati washington chicago the
gulf back to washington for the new york
times what's all that about
i have
quit a lot of jobs at one
time or another
to try different things i started out in
television in new york
working for good morning america as a
booker
and i quit that to become a newspaper
reporter in cincinnati and
quit that to become a newspaper reporter
in baltimore and then in washington and
eventually quit that to become a
freelancer um because max
uh
had gotten a job in chicago and i wanted
to follow her so i went to chicago to
freelance and
that's where i started writing magazine
pieces and and longer writing now that
you're back here in washington at the
white house for the new york times where
is she she's here i'm happy to say we're
married
and what does she do she's a producer
for cbs news here in washington
if you were to name one
part of this book that left the biggest
impression or the experience around the
part of the book that he wrote which one
would it be
i suppose uh
the biggest impression on me
i suppose
some of the things i saw in and around
kuwait city i had never seen
before and i don't think
many people have seen
what happens to a place that is occupied
by an army out of control
and
much of
and this this got to to what i
was talking about earlier about the
difference between the sort of
euphemistic
way in which we sometimes talk about
things in the way they really are
the what happened in kuwait city uh was
so extraordinary
and to to walk through it to see
the endless blocks of gutted and looted
and
savaged uh
buildings and to go through the morgues
and and see the torture you know i spent
one whole afternoon just in the morgue
going from torture victim to torture
victim
to to talk to the people and to
uh
to see to hear their
their terror and so on uh that made a
great impression on me because i thought
that i thought then and i think now that
there was some
misunderstanding perhaps in this country
about
why
in a moral sense this war might be
considered necessary or just
uh
and i had my own doubts about that
before i went to kuwait city
and after that i never had any doubts
about it again that
when you see what actually happens to a
people
who
uh
are taken by a hostile army
and
by an army that is intent on a campaign
of
looting and murder and
and rape and so on uh
it removes in a very clarifying way any
confusion you might have had in your
mind about whether it was a good or a
bad idea to stop this sort of thing
was it
worth all the
price that this country paid for in my
mind yes i mean in my mind it was
absolutely worth it first of all we paid
a very small price um
the the coin of war is death and we paid
almost nothing
uh in that coin
um
in financial terms i think the price was
uh quite bearable
in terms of what it netted this country
the obvious
things the
the stopping of the threat to the oil
supply the obvious economic reasons are
enough but it also i think
sent an astonishing message about the
united states to the world that was
worth a great deal and that
uh
that message uh
is
in keeping with the message that is now
being sent
in somalia the notion that
a great power the soul remaining great
power
might be willing to use massive force to
stop something terrible from happening
for reasons that are at least in part
altruistic
in other words for reasons at least in
part because it is the necessary good
thing to do is a tremendous thing to do
and it won us much more i think than we
realize in the middle east when i went
over for that first trip to baghdad
naman
the conventional wisdom in amman
the writing in the newspapers the talk
among the intelligentsia was all to the
effect that the united states who was
obviously
in working in concert with israel was
going to use this as an excuse to start
a new program of colonization of the
middle east that once american troops
were in they would never leave that they
would end up taking the riches for
themselves and when the united states
did not do this when it did what it said
it was going to do
to restore
kuwait to the kuwaitis and then to to
leave
it went i found when i went back to aman
a year later
uh
a very long way to changing the
perceptions of at least some people in
the arab world about the united states
to seeing the united states is not
not necessarily and completely evil
which is
has been the prevailing view for many
years
your first trip ever to the middle east
my second i had gone to israel before
but never to the arab world
one of the things that you get in the
book is a little bit of a travelogue i
know it was under rather restricted
circumstances but
let me go through the countries you're
in and just to have you do it quickly
give us some of the
feelings you have about those places try
israel for a moment what do you think of
it i had um i was
uh
tremendously taken
uh with
with one great uh difference between
israel before the war and the second
time i went during this gut attacks and
when i went to israel the uh the first
time uh before the war began it seemed
to me a country in something of a funk
the intifada had been going on
i think it was in its third year i
believe and it had recently escalated to
knife attacks and gun attacks as opposed
to merely stone throwing
the
political debate was utterly polarized
but
with left and right and very few people
left in the center having a voice
there was an awful lot of talk about
depression and
uh
you know a neurotic society and so on
and so on uh i went back
during these gut attacks and found a
country that was
living like london in the blitz
a country where merely being there
staying in tel aviv during the war not
running away
was an act of conspicuous bravery so
that a person could
become a hero
and that's a rare and difficult thing
for a person to become
simply by getting up in the morning and
going to work in tel aviv and it
did a wonderful thing for that society
people were bursting with
with joy at
being israeli again and that
at the
to the israelis astonishing
the fact that for the first time in the
history of the jews
another people was were had proved
itself willing to actually fight on
behalf
of jews when the americans came in with
the patriots missiles
to the israelis that was astonishing
that some
that
the non-jewish people would come in and
say yeah we're on your side we'll fight
we'll fight for you and with you on this
uh it
it did an awful lot to the to the
national psyche or for the national
psyche it did what did it do for
american servicemen stationed there with
the patriots turner it must have been a
wonderful time for them i mean i
um
i could only see see it as an observer
um but uh
they were they were the toast of tel
aviv which is a a beach town and a and
uh to some degree a party town so it's
a place that would naturally be fun for
a young american servicemen to be
but in this case i think it must have
been wonderful i mean they couldn't walk
down the street without
women coming up to kiss them and
you know men coming up to shake their
hands people would invite them home for
dinner
people would
there were billboards all over the city
thanking them
advertisements in the newspapers
thanking them every day
cairo
cairo
i found
i suppose in odd way the most
intimidating place i saw just because it
is so
overwhelming uh there are i think 12
million people in cairo now and
it is approaching society as a black
hole it's so dense that nothing can
escape uh
and i was uh
only in cairo for a matter of days
trying to get from there to saudi arabia
for the beginning of the ground war but
it it was long enough i i thought i
liked cairo it was exciting but it was
like new york but new york ratcheted up
10 degrees above even where new york is
today i mean everything is noise
everything is chaos and confusion what
about the egyptians the people they're
wonderful uh they were of all the people
i
met in my travels uh
i suppose the people i
liked uh
the most immediately i traveled during
the gulf war uh dan fassberg meant a
reporter for the baltimore sun and i
traveled with the egyptian army
the american army at that time was
had
all these elaborate rules about press
participation and coverage it seemed to
me to make coverage
almost impossible or at least not worth
worth doing really um
and
one of the rules was that if you weren't
part of the pool system they would
actually arrest you and put you in a
stockade for the night the egyptians
didn't care at all dan and i just sort
of wandered into an egyptian army
column on the uh
morning of the second day of the war and
asked
a major or if we could tag along and he
said well sure why not i mean it's a
free desert
and
that was a whole attitude towards you
know sure why not
get back to that that trip during the
actual war itself but um
uh when you travel
how do you keep track of all this do you
keep a diaries you want every day i take
um
an awful lot of notes um i suppose i
filled uh 40 or 50 notebooks uh
during the actual war and i
i write every night and i try to write
every night in the hotel
room longer things reflections and and
so on that doesn't feel in notes at the
moment but a lot of notes but if we saw
you traipsing about in the middle of
writing this book uh would you be
weighted down with all your notebooks
and a
a pc or yes i traveled very heavy which
was a problem i uh
by the
i never know how to under pack and uh
by the end of the my last trip when i
went to kurdistan one of the reasons it
was so
difficult getting out of
kurdish iraq
was that i had somehow gotten to the
point where i was carrying three large
pieces of luggage and as somebody who
didn't have a car
it's a sort of insanity i i know other
travelers who have this problem but i i
never throw anything away i pack
everything i save local newspapers
wherever i go and i get heavier and
heavier and heavier
and i end up you know with 150 pounds of
stuff sort of dragging behind me
how about interpreters by the way i uh
hired interpreters uh as i went along uh
in each country
either for a week or for a day or
something but i'd i went every day with
an interpreter i don't speak arabic
and you find an awful lot of people who
speak english
but you really should have you need to
have an interpreter with you um is it
freelancer do you have to pay for that
yourself yes i had to pay for everything
myself and get reimbursed as i was sort
of
maxing out credit cards and
rolling the debt along and
beseeching editors for
reimbursements to keep going and how
expensive is it to hire a interpreter
for a day
not too bad it depends on where you are
but anywhere uh it depends on the market
as driven by how many journalists
foreign journalists are in the country
but it could be anything from a few
dollars a day to 150 bucks a day
again it's all market driven how did you
travel between these countries i would
uh
either fly in or drive in and then once
i was in the country i would
sometimes i would i rented a car a
nissan a four-wheel drive kind of thing
with dan and i to
uh cover the ground war itself so we
could just drive through the desert um
through iran in iraq i uh
i sort of half hitchhiked and half took
taxis
in iran i took taxes in iraq uh in
kurdish iraq i mean i mostly just
hitchhiked from one rebel group to
another they would pass me along
in baghdad it's easy to travel uh
there's tons of taxi cabs there you just
take a cab and you usually have a minder
with you
in a government car sometimes too
and when you did you ever run into a
situation where did no one spoke english
yes a couple times um
the uh
i guess no more than a couple times
fairly often you'd run into something
but never in such a way that it was a a
tremendous problem that i was in in
trouble that i couldn't get out of
because no one spoke english
usually
there will be somebody in a position of
authority if you get stopped by an army
patrol or something
fairly low down on the level on of
authority on the level of lieutenant or
something
you'll find somebody who speaks english
because everyone is taught english in
schools in every arab country i think
you write about the difficulty of going
from israel
to an arab country
and the need for a couple of passports
and all that what's the reason for that
how does that work the
israel occupies this odd state in the in
the
arab mind it's a
at once a double state and
simultaneously it doesn't exist
so that there can be no official
intercourse between israel and the arab
world you can't place a phone call
from oman to
tel aviv
even though the two cities are only
a few miles apart really
but
because it's in everybody's interest to
keep
to keep
communication open for commerce and for
other reasons
all sorts of elaborate dodges have been
built into the system to allow people to
actually to act to actually travel and
to communicate for instance if you go to
a travel i went to a travel agency in
amman to get from amman to
jerusalem now you can't do that directly
but you can you can fly to larnica on
cyprus which is a just a hop of a flight
and then fly from there
to tel aviv and then drive to jerusalem
and
everybody will work with you to make
that possible even though you're not
really supposed
officially you're not supposed to be
doing this but the whole system works on
everybody looking the other way so let
me ask you just a quick question you fly
from amman to lernica is how long oh i
suppose it's about a uh
less than an hour from larnica to tel
aviv airport
20 minutes or something from the tel
aviv ben green airport to jerusalem how
long it's a half hour drive
40 minute drive
um if you drove directly from oman to
jerusalem you could drive the whole
thing in about i think two hours or
something
um crossing the allen b bridge but you
keep everybody travels everybody who
routinely goes from in from the israel
from israel to the arab world or vice
versa keeps two passports one stamped
good for israel and egypt only
since egypt does allow
correspondence since camp david with
israel and the other for the rest of the
world so that when you go in
to
if you go from larnica for instance to
uh
to tel aviv when you enter israel you
use your
israel only passport and when you exit
israel on the other end let's say to go
as i went from the border near the gaza
strip to drive across the sinai to cairo
you use that again but entering
entering
on the other side of the line the
egyptian immigrations and customs
building you use your rest of world
passport now the egyptian customs
officer knows that you came from
somewhere
that the last entry in your passport is
uh
for entering uh larnica
and there's a gap of time and he knows
very well you've just crossed israel but
everybody is committed to the notion of
of looking the other way if necessary
and the telephone system works that way
too that
the travel agent i work with in amman to
make that trip for instance she asked me
if i needed a
hotel room in jerusalem
and i said no i was going to stay uh
with with max in tel aviv but she said
well if you did it's easy for me to
range as well how can you arrange that
and she said oh i have a cousin in
brooklyn
he has a fax machine uh the phone is set
up the autumn the phone on the fax
machine is auto automatically set up to
forward the call to another cousin we
have in jerusalem so i fax my cousin in
brooklyn his phone
forwards the facts to jerusalem the
cousin in jerusalem reads the facts
makes you a hotel reservation it takes
two minutes
when you're in cairo you went from there
to where and what what time frame are we
talking about i drove
from the border across the sinai uh to
cairo and that took only a day
and then from cairo uh
hung around for a few days beseeching
the saudis for a visa and then
went from saudi arabia to bahrain to
dharan
arriving in durham about i suppose two
days before the beginning of the ground
war by the way this isn't your actual
passport
here that is actually a picture of the
visa the iraqi v zone uh from my
passport
uh my editor uh
had to make a picture of that do you
have much to say so about the size of
this book the you know the actual not
the number of pages but it's a smaller
book to hold yeah and uh and and what
the cover looked like i had uh
a wonderful editor sharon delano at
random house and the size of the book
the way the cover looks and so on uh all
reflected her ideas of the way she
thought it should look and i i thought
it was beautiful actually by the time it
was finished i was very happy about it
have you had any surprise reactions from
people who read this
um a few my
my mother and a few other
people in my family were sort of annoyed
at me for not mentioning more at the
time about how sick i'd been in
kurdistan and finding about out about in
the book i had not really
mentioned it an awful lot um a few
people have uh
have seen things in it that i
i didn't see when i wrote it and i think
it
to some degree is a is a book that
people see and what they want to see
a couple people have told me that they
saw you know what my views were about
the gulf war
and so on and which are not explicitly
stated in the book
uh and i it was interesting to me to
find out that everybody sort of saw my
views as as what they wanted to see that
those who were
against the gulf war thought it was a
needless war that the united states had
acted improperly some people who hold
that view
which is not mine have told me that they
can see that in my riding and others who
thought
that the gulf war
was a necessary war and that the united
states prosecuted it
well
have told me that they can see that in
the writing
cairo
getting into saudi arabia how'd you get
there
uh
it's not that hard you just need to
fly to bahrain and then you can drive
over the causeway into dharan which is
an oil pumping city that if you remember
was the
uh sort of a jumping off
point for the ground war
uh in iran uh
i i did not want to take part in the
pool system and uh
wanted to go uh
out by myself or with a partner
dan
so we had to spend a day or two getting
outfitted uh
renting a
four-wheel drive and
scrounging around to get
some military clothes so we could sort
of try to pass ourselves off as
belonging there
what about the inverted
v we we found that uh the
the allied troops had had painted
inverted v's on all of their vehicles as
a sign to them to themselves that that
vehicle was proper and belonged
in the combat zone
and so
we
went to a safeway or of some sort and
daron and bought masking tape and
colored it black with magic marker i
mean a pathetic exercise and it wouldn't
fool anybody
but to my surprise it got us through i
mean we would gut to checkpoints and
there would be a military policeman
there and they would see the inverted v
and salute and
dan and i look less like soldiers and uh
than anybody else and we were always
amazed at this work but it did work
fairly well we would get turned back at
a few places but
by and large we were able to wander
around at will the first day of the gulf
war was
the i'm not sure if i remember the date
exactly now uh
1991
yeah was it the 21st i think of february
something long
the first day of the ground war or the
well the bombing just want a time frame
from where we're talking right now
because i wanted to ask you this here we
are about two years later right
the day we're taping this the
announcement was made that pete williams
is going to become a
he was the former spokesman during the
war time going to become a correspondent
for nbc they've resigned tom kelly the
general who did all the briefing here in
washington to be a consultant at nbc
norman schwarzkopf has written his book
made lots of money walking around the
united states making speeches
you're now at the white house for the
new york times
and a man that you write about a lot in
here george bush is in town this evening
this particularly when we're taping this
to give the only speech that he's given
since he was defeated for president
right
anything come to mind
two years later i am
i was i suppose like everyone else
surprised that the that the successful
prosecution of the gulf war
bore such
meager political fruit for george bush i
would have thought
and i think most people would have
thought
during that week in which
we were watching the victory parades in
new york and in washington that there
would be tremendous resonance
from this
and
i don't really know why that there
wasn't i don't know if it's because we
now live in such a
an astonishingly fast-paced and and sort
of information overloaded society that
nothing has resonance beyond a few weeks
anymore i mean that that seems to me one
possibility everything
uh is utterly transient now in politics
uh you're a hero because of this and a
month later you're a goat because of
some economic figures
um
i think that a different politician a
better politician somebody who was
actually good at communicating as bill
clinton is could have made the residents
stick could have gotten a good deal more
political mileage out of out of the gulf
war
george bush always struck me as having
an astonishing lack of ability to seize
an emotional moment
and make it his own as ronald reagan
always had this tremendous ronald reagan
could see his emotional moments that had
nothing to do with him
that he had no claim on that for
instance uh
going to uh the beaches to for the
remembrance of uh the landing at
normandy that that is not anything that
ronald reagan had anything to do with
but he was he he knew how to use
communications to use
people like us and to use television to
make that work for him george bush had
all had the opposite trait that
something
would happen on his watch something of
extraordinary power such as the
fall of the berlin wall
and he
would show no ability to take it and
make that politically his own moment
bill clinton or ronald reagan if the
berlin wall fell while they were
president would have been over at
checkpoint charlie so fast
and standing on the wall you know uh
right there in a perfect shot
bush i think in a communications age
greatly suffers from not
not having that ability
correct me if i'm wrong but i don't see
you in this book hardly ever talking to
officialdom the people that i just
mentioned were people that you don't
talk about in here i didn't cover any i
didn't spend any time with them i spent
no time uh
in any of the
with any of the official structure at
all i i did spend some time talking to
american soldiers uh and officers but on
a fairly low level
people that i've
found on the battlefield and and
in kuwait city and places like that and
just talked to but i
didn't have any real contact with the
officialdom do they know who you were i
don't think so do they care who you were
when i got to duron they asked me to
sign some paper saying that i would be
part of the pool system and it was i
tried to read it it ran to three or four
pages of dense type
and it seemed to prohibit everything i
could imagine wanting to do
uh so i i didn't sign it and
went and got some coffee instead
if you were there now with the new york
times would you have to sign yeah
i would have yeah that's one of the
great advantages of being a freelancer
is that
you exist outside
the rules that grown-ups make
i mean the pool system was a compact
between the military and the american
news organization so that
who worked for a news organization as a
staffer and i had friends who
suffered greatly from this who were felt
tremendously frustrated in their ability
to get out and cover the war
any but anybody in their position was
was part of that compact
a new york times reporter would be part
of that compact or a washington post
reporter or a boston globe reporter or
anybody
now do you feel any different when you
sit down to your typewriter or your pc
or however you do that that's do you
carry your own portable with you yeah i
carry a
little radio shack or something like
that i mean the difference between
running around in the middle east by
yourself
and now working for
the establishment new york times what
what goes on in your head when you sit
down to the typewriter
i um
i suppose that i think a lot about
the
the ability you have
in writing a book uh
something of that length and something
with without
without the conventions of journalism to
bind it
the ability you have to to tell a story
in
in detail and to use the accrual of
detail to paint pictures
i think if i miss anything in
newspaper writing it's that it's
difficult to do that in newspaper
writing
because of the limitations of time and
space and because of the conventions of
of newspaper writing on the back of your
book you have a note on here from robert
hughes author of the fatal shores you
know him no
how do they get something like this um i
think that the uh publishing uh company
uh routinely
uh asks uh
authors and
and
other writers when they have a book
coming out to read advanced copies and
give what amounts to a review quote
back to the book itself
you did
join the egyptians there in the middle
of that war how did you find them
physically yeah i was sort of dan and i
were uh wandering
somewhat lost uh through the uh
desert looking for an army um
a little embarrassed at least i was
because we had been looking at that
point for an army for
many hours it took us we couldn't find
the war at first
uh and which is a mildly humiliating i
mean
to go out
and be prepared and have your fake
inverted v on your car and everything
and to not be able to find uh the
largest ground battle uh in history uh
but we we did find it eventually and and
i suppose by accident as i remember we
were just driving along and we
ran into
uh
all of a sudden a very large group of uh
men with guns and tanks and um we were
we knew right away that that was an army
how'd they treat you they were great
they treated us wonderfully
yes somewhat
they
they let us come along with them they
let us uh watch them do whatever they
were doing we didn't get to see
much in the way of fighting because
there wasn't much in the way of fighting
uh
in the ground war a
testimony i think to the extraordinary
job in which
which the allied forces and the american
military did in waging the war
they
they had so
overwhelmed
the iraqis who were
i think except for the republican guard
at best a reluctant enemy the average
iraqi private was not at all interested
in dying for saddam hussein in the
trenches
that by the time when the ground war
began
it would be unfair to say that there was
no fighting because
it would suggest that the soldiers
didn't have a job to do which is wrong
they did i think they did it
extraordinarily well but there was an
awful lot more surrendering
than there was fighting most iraqis gave
up as soon as they could
and to anyone they could give up to tell
the story when you came upon
you're in your
nissan
truck or was it
four-wheel drive
and you came upon the
uh iraqi
soldiers
that would have been the second i guess
day of the ground war and or the third
and dan and i were trying to get to
kuwait city because it was clear that
the war was for all practical purposes
over
and we wanted
if you remember it only lasted 100 hours
we wanted to get to kuwait city uh for
the liberation
um
we were dr we were trying to make our
way up a highway that ran inside iraq
ultimately to kuwait city
and
picking our way through it slowly
because the iraqis had
set dynamite charges
in places across the roads to to stop
you from going forward and because there
were mine fields all around and not all
of them were marked and you had to sort
of watch your step
and
we it was dusk and it was raining and it
was miserable and we came suddenly upon
a group of
a wretched looking men
holding waving a standing in the middle
of the road waving a a white flag
a t-shirt on a piece of bamboo i think
and they were clearly iraqis and they
were unarmed and they were
they cut a pathetic site i mean they
they were desperate to to surrender
because it was getting on tonight it was
freezing cold and it was raining and i
don't think any of them had eaten in
some time
and they were
afraid that if they stayed out on the
battlefield somebody might mistake them
for
something people worthy of killing
so they
they asked to surrender to us and
we didn't we didn't want to do it i mean
we were we tried to tell them we were
not in that line of work that we were
just the two of you yeah give an
interpreter with you this time no and
they sort of only one of them spoke
english and was very little bit but it
was clear
and we
fumbled our way
i think at least for myself in a state
of mild embarrassment through this
um
exchange where
we were
like people trying to beg off from a
dinner party invitation we didn't want
any part of it we just wanted to
leave them alone we gave them a lot of
our food
and orange juice and things like that
but we didn't want to take prisoners
because it seemed
it wasn't our role i mean we were not in
in the prisoner taking business
uh
so we pushed on and
went on a little further but were turned
back by a a
minefield that had not been cleared
um by the way just uh i kept asking
myself when i read your book how did you
fuel where'd you get we would uh i i
bought uh we bought in kuwait city
before we set out
15 big jerry cans
at the hardware store or something like
that and filled them up with gasoline
and carried
um
we carried them with us in the back of
the uh thing
at all times um so you know anywhere
between 10 and 15
jerry ken's filled up with gas um so
anyway you pushed on you had to found
the minefield and then you turned around
turned back because it was getting dark
and if the minefield wasn't cleared we
were not going to try to get across it
and dark with uh
i guess work and
came back and saw the
poor guys still trudging along in the
rain and it was just too miserable to
leave them there so
we took them not as prisoners but more
as taxi drivers
i mean we we were
not uh this was not an act of of uh
subjugation on our part we were merely
escorting them uh
and
they climbed on top of the car and in
the car and so on and we get them a
little farther on
and to give them to the first army unit
which we we ran across which was a saudi
brigade supply brigade that had not seen
any action and
they went
uh bananas over the prospect of of
capturing the enemy and
um
went around jamming clips into their
rifles and
yelling and so on and terrifying the
kuwaitis who thought that they were all
going to be shot in the sand and so the
kuwaiti i mean the iraqis so the
iraqis are crying and carrying on and
you know praying and the saudis are
yelling and
dan and i are standing there
bemused at the side
and
not knowing i suppose i didn't know what
to
do
but it
it devolved very quickly into something
that wasn't again sort of
not like what you think of a surrender
in a time of war the saudis had no real
interest in
hurting the iraqis there there was
always among the arab troops a sense of
kinship
with the iraqis a sense that they were
after all islam and arabic and that they
should not
be killed the egyptian army for instance
went to i think considerable pains from
what i saw to avoid killing iraqis
they would not
they were they would wait and let people
come to them and surrender rather than
take a building by storm and so on
there's one point though you uh
said that you saw one of the saudi
soldiers go over and give the iraqi a
kiss
yes at the very end uh
which uh
i i suppose was a signal to all of us
that nothing bad was going to happen uh
the
the saudis calmed saudi soldiers calmed
down a bit and as they calmed down the
iraqis started to calm down and one of
them went up and there was one iraqi who
was sort of weeping and clutching at
himself and he gave him a kiss i think
on each cheek and then everybody sort of
relaxed
you went to kuwait
i went to kuwait uh how long did it take
you by the way from that time not too
long we the next morning we went back to
that highway and uh the minefield had
had been cleared in the early morning
by i suppose american and perhaps
egyptian troops and there was a path
through it and that was the last
minefield between us and kuwait city so
we were able
to get to kuwait city by about noon of
that day uh and
uh get past a few checkpoints into the
city itself
time has gone by fast but some things
that people there's left for people to
read in this book you spend how much
time in in kuwait i spent about two or
three weeks i think
in kuwait and in the environs around
kuwait up to the iraqi border and so on
and
up the highways where the iraqi army had
retreated uh
and had been uh
if you remember
the roads where they were blown up and
so on in retreat uh about two weeks
mostly one copy back at this time there
was in kuwait uh
a fairly
fairly quickly
enough in the way of communications that
you could dictate
uh things two or three news
organizations at least no more than that
probably six or seven bought in
satellite phones all the networks had
one
and the boston globe
for whom i was stringing had
half share in a satellite phone
with a time magazine i think
and i think maybe one other news
organization so you could get a
satellite phone out in the evening what
are people at the boston globe and the
new republic and places like that
telling you why you're over there what
is it they like
what is it they want more of
you couldn't get a there wasn't enough
time to have long conversations about a
lot of stuff but i think
uh most of the reporting that was done
in kuwait
city uh
was
i mean to some degree self-evident you
come into a city where
that has been occupied by an army and is
now liberated then the you know you
there are
you're going to cover two things one the
story of the liberation and two the
story of what it had been like under
occupation so every day you just go out
and
do a different facet of that story is
there any one piece that you wrote while
you're over there for any of these
publications that got the most feedback
i think probably the uh
i wrote a piece uh
just before i left kuwait city about
the emir's new palace for the new
republic that
uh to the
effect that the u.s army corps of
engineers was involved in the business
of refurbishing
along extremely swank lines uh a palace
for the emir who was coming home to
kuwait after sitting out the war and
luxury digs elsewhere
and you know the the spectacle of
the army corps of engineers supervising
workers doing things like putting fresh
silk up on the walls and
installing new gold faucets for the
bathrooms in a city where people were
still
without food or water and so on
i think got a lot of attention you also
write some about sanctions did they work
no i don't think they did i don't think
they ever would have
i think that
the smuggling uh
links which have now been amply proven
between jordan and iraq
would have always kept enough
going
that the country
could not be forced into
into compliance with the united nations
well by sanctions alone
mostly because the people who run iraq
saddam hussein and his uh
his
fellow bath party
leaders and military leaders and so on
they run a gangster state and which they
control absolutely and the notion that
the sanctions might cause tremendous
suffering to the people of iraq which
they did and indeed still do
is not i don't think a tremendous
concern
the people who run iraq the men who want
run iraq still eat quite well and drink
quite well and have mistresses and
very nice mercedes that they took from
kuwait and so on in their life it's not
that painful
white house correspondent for the new
york times is that the pinnacle
i don't know i never thought of that is
it i often you always want it yes sure
why not
what's it mean what kind of a job is it
um
it's uh
it's a fun job right now this is an
i suppose a
one of the best of all times to be
watching a new administration since this
administration is trying to do so much
so quickly
there's a there is a sense every day i
think for most people in
in
our line of work in washington that
you're here at a time
where there is an awful lot of
substantive change about to happen or
in the midst of happening and that that
is that is thrilling get any sense of
what the white house
thinks of you
no i don't uh have any great sense but i
don't really i suppose look for any
great sense of it
any sense of what you think of them i'm
still in a process of learning about
them i don't really
i mean
they are a work in progress
i don't try not to form any
final
conclusions about them or anybody else i
cover on a day-to-day
basis people treat you differently now
that you're in this job
um
i don't know uh
my mother doesn't
not at all or my wife so
i don't i don't think too much now your
father is a
reporter for the washington times
you say he influenced you to get into
this business tremendously what was it
like growing up in the family it was
great fun we grew up on capitol hill and
my
parents ran a uh
i suppose a kind of typical newspaper
family house and there were always
people over for dinner and
there was always lots of
commotion at the dinner table and lots
of people arguing about
the events of the day and
a lot of excitement in the air i i grew
up
watching
grown-ups
argue around the dinner table at great
length about things that they were not
particularly well informed on which is
excellent training for her life in
washington
what'd your mom do my mom is also a
writer she writes about child care for
a the washington post and other
newspapers she has a syndicated column
and writes books on child care also
what's her column called uh her the
family almanac
marguerite kelly
and she wrote
she writes books called the mother's
almanac and mother's almanac too
and after a year or so in this book by
the way is there going to be a paperback
on it yes there is
what's the best thing that people will
say about this book from your standpoint
i would be happy if they said that the
writing was good i
i wanted to write something that was not
not a journalistic account as much as it
was
a piece of writing i wanted to write
something that
would use writing to look at the way war
affects what happens in times of war not
the gulf war but war in general and the
way people are and the way they behave
i'd be very happy about that
this is what the book looks like our
guest has been michael kelly the author
it's all about his
trips over to the middle east during the
gulf war it's called martyr's day
chronicle of a small war thank you very
much for joining us thanks for having me
michael kelly was killed thursday night
while covering the war in iraq he was
embedded with the army's third infantry
division and was killed in a humvee
accident he's the first american
journalist to die in the current
conflict he was 46 years old
you